vous avez chez quand vous étiez prêts
dans la semaine nationale ne peut pas
dire que vous n'avez pas fait ce serait
effectivement de la démagogie mais avez
vous été au bout je ne crois pas je
crois qu'on doit tout remettre à plat
dans la transparence la plus absolue
pour dire qu'à un moment donné
un député qui est aussi adjoint au maire
ce qui peut pas être maire aujourd'hui
député m ces municipales il peut être
conseillé municipal
il peut donc cumuler donc une indemnité
de conseiller municipal
il faudrait que ça s'arrête il a une
indemnité de député
si votre conseiller municipal il n'a pas
accumulé l'indemnité de conseil
municipal
ça c'est une première chose deuxième
chose vous parlez de même dire que c'est
plafonné oui mais c'est vrai qu'on y met
d'accord mais jusqu'au plafond avoir une
semaine dignité quand on a sept mille et
quelques euros ça suffit quand même
de quel moment donné la permanence elles
se chiffrent à combien monsieur le
ministre mais j'ai dit les frais de
mandat ça a été dit ces 5000 euros par
mois bon c'est milo et vous parliez de
votre permanence à 1500 mais est ce
qu'on a besoin de 5000 euros
est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir une chiffre
un peu plus précis parce qu'on
al'impression la queue on manie des
chiffres on peut avec laxisme avec la la
grosse maille comme on dit non si on me
dit vous devez trouver une permanence
entre 1000 et 2000 euros point barre
vous avez le chiffre qui va bien ça
c'est le deuxième point
donc il faut pas connu une enveloppe de
ses mines quand une permanence de
recruter 2000
donc ça c'est une chose et 3e - gratuité
des lignes sncf il me services est une
entreprise publique de caisse qui est en
déficit
la sangle bay semble être oui ça
semblait paye mais le député sur son
indemnité de 7000 euros
moi j'aimerais bien éventuellement qui
le 2 3 allers retours entre sa
circonscription et paris normal qu'on le
prenne en charge mais qu'il est la
gratuité de 3 par an il va pas y aller
ça non non non non je parle pas de 3 par
an aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui deux fois par semaine
aujourd'hui la gratuité est totale sur
une barque mais attendez mais un député
en premier afin qu'à la ville avait été
député européen vous alliez pas
une fois dedans qui commence d'ailleurs
au passage sont beaucoup plus importants
et les alliés pas non mais quatre coins
du monde rit sur aux quatre coins de la
jalousie parce que le parlement la
ministre de notamment la perche alors
parce que alors là je vais vous dire
faisons ce qu'on fait au parlement mais
les moyens de fonctionner mais voulait
pas entendre ce match 6 à 6,6 alors
qu'on a le billet thalys gratuit quand
on est parlement européen vous devez le
savoir vous croyez qu'on a le billet
gratuit je crois qu'ils ont juste une
quiche mais c'est sérieux ne cédez vous
nous parlez deviendra de il ya bien
mettez nous sied parfaitement
le billet il est payé à 70% perdre à 30%
de réduction parce qu'on fait l'aller
retour sur notre indemnité
d'accord je suis désolé il a tempêté
d'être combien député européen à peu
près pareil c'est moi je vis ta vie tes
seins mais là aussi on m'avait demandé
mon sur facebook
est-ce que vous toucher une retraite non
il n'y a pas de retraite ça sort du
fantasme
je pense que le modèle européen est pas
un mauvais modèle de ce mail
eric naulleau la réponse du ministre
s'en est inspirée semblait paye ça veut
dire que c'est les français qui payent
blessures c'est bien je m'attendais bien
sûr mais il ya un budget de l'assemblée
ah oui ma fille n'a pas bougé d'accord
depuis 10 ans 500 millions de rezé la
rotation annuel
ça pourrait passer pas les salaires qui
me choque l'audio tout début ces
désavantages et privés avec ses des
privilèges qui me sens complètement mais
basé sur rien